the University of California Student
Association which represents 233,000
students enrolled in you sees 10
campuses here in California have voted
to divest from the United States of
America yeah that's right we've got some
info for you the government of the
United States of America is engaged in
drone strikes that have killed over
2,400 people in Pakistan and Yemen many
of them civilians the government
oversees by far the highest rate of
imprisonment in the world and racial and
ethnic minorities are disproportionately
targeted by law enforcement agencies
particularly for drug-related offenses
it goes on 400,000 undocumented
immigrants are held in detention centers
every year and millions have been
deported since the current
administration took office and the
government is directly supporting and
propping up numerous dictatorships
around the world with weapon sales and
foreign aid and finally this resolution
aims neither should condemn the entire
country's people's or communities nor to
determine political solutions but it is
solely aimed at ending our universities
support of governments that directly
engage in and enable humans rights
violations okay so look we talk all the
time here about misguided foreign policy
that we do when we start wars that we
screw up things and maybe Isis is our
fault because we took Saddam out and he
was kind of keeping everything under
control over there and drone strikes
that are making more people hate us than
killing bad guys all of that stuff that
being said this strikes me as incredibly
naive and and silly for colleges to say
we're going to divest meaning take all
their money the money that they have
invested in either United States
contracts or companies that do business
the United States Senator they're gonna
take their money out of it uh it seems
really short-sighted and something that
only college kids I know they think they
know everything but that only they would
do it's it's it seems crazy because it's
impossible so um in doing so I think
they know that you know it's almost
seems like it's a ploy is to flip
another word but just like it's their
way of putting out there if you don't
know about what's going on after we make
this huge announcement or at least you
know this resolution we want to put
the maybe hope you know that's happening
I feel like it's a talking I did you
that so you are an effective statement I
think because it's it's the classic sort
of coke or pepsi thing if you say all
that stuff that a certain country is
doing to someone they go my god that's
terrible then you lift the lid on the
United States you're soaking in it you
know and so I I mean yet though on a
practical level this may not work but I
I think it's a great way to sort of
initiate a conversation about this kind
of thing because we're constantly
judging what other people are doing and
we're invading them or were cutting off
money or were this over that based on
you know x y&z behavior but it's not
like we're coming to any of this with a
clean slate ourselves when I was in
college back in the eighties that's how
old I am yeah the big thing was
divesting from South Africa you know
because of apartheid yeah but it's not
like our racial history's been all that
great either so who you know when you're
pointing a finger at other countries
you're for or pointing back at the
Pentagon right so I guess that that's
sort of the irony here but all right so
if it's just a PR stunt then then I get
it there they're shining a light on it
and these are issues that we talk about
your all the time so I'm not against the
issues we imprison way too many people
again the drugs are all the wars all
that stuff um but what about the college
element to this like it seems to me that
I would back out of who all the kids
that voted for this thing a lot of them
really do believe in this thing not in
the you know that this is really gonna
make a difference in a if our college
students can be recklessly idealistic
yeah I ask you right the mean the second
half for at least the resolution that
the final touches have to be and
therefore we put our resources to which
country who was right so who do right so
who's the good guys then Ben & Jerry's
Ben and Jerry's will do but really like
who who really are the good guys and
that that's where I was waiting for the
final point cuz in a little bit i was
reading and going yeah they can be
serious I mean I get it but they can be
says but maybe they'll have some kind of
no director / at the end they're putting
it all in tom's of maine yeah you know I
don't know what I'm to me that's the
toothpaste one right yes I use that
toothpaste what about TOMS shoes that's
another thing tom they give shoes too
impoverished people like I wonder why
can't these come to be called Jamal's
why time has everything tom how about
you because Jamal can't get a [ __ ]
break in this country because we're
imprisoning too many people of color
that's why we brought it all around
anyway what do you think is this good PR
just to get light on these issues or it
is totally misguided I'm sort in between
the two I get it but I don't know it
just seems kind of silly hey we let us
know in the comments right now